[Music]
at least since the baby yoda memes of
the star wars series the mandalorian has
become known and popular beyond the
borders of disney plus users
it's no surprise that disney does
everything to make season 2 as
successful as the first season and to
meet the high expectations of the fans
in addition to the main series disney
boss bob chappeck admits that he may
also provide a spin-off for the new
characters introduced in the coming
season
this could also involve the return of
familiar characters from the original
star wars saga
as the series is set shortly after the
saga concerning the plot there will be
some questions to be answered anyway
therefore pero pascal is the title
giving mandalorian will return to his
role
but we will also get to see temura
morrison in his new role as boba fett
by the way in a recent interview favreau
also announced that the pandemic
wouldn't hinder the production of a
possible third season too much as the
number of people actually on the set
isn't really high due to the elaborate
computer animations
a trailer will probably be shown during
the first playoff around the nba
season 2 will then be released in
october
on september 3rd christopher nolan's
highly anticipated film tenant will be
released in u.s cinemas
as it has been known since this week the
film will get top class musical support
just before the star the superstar
travis scott will contribute the title
song for attendant as director
christopher nolan confirmed in an
interview with gq
travis scott's distinctive voice is the
last piece of the puzzle the film is
missing
until the very end they will work on the
last pieces of the puzzle until in a few
days
we will get to see the according to his
own statement
most ambitious project of the inception
and memento director
the us magazine collider reports that
the blockbuster will cost an impressive
225 million us dollars
and that is without any further
nine-figure marketing costs
robert pattinson and john david
washington will star in the leading
roles and according to the trailers and
speculations that have been circulating
so far
they will pay special attention to time
travel tenant will be released in a few
days on september 3rd
by the way you can listen to travis
scott's title song the plan
since friday
fans of the matrix series have been
wondering for quite some time whether
there is no information about morpheus
or his actor laurence fishburne since
fishburn played a very significant role
in the first three parts
especially concerning the plot his
unshakable belief in neo and the
prediction of the oracle as an important
part of the story remains in our minds
in an interview with new york magazine
it now becomes clear why fishburne did
not return to his role
he was simply not asked especially in
view of the announced efforts of the
wikowski sisters to bring many familiar
faces back to the screen in the fourth
part
fishburne's statement comes as a big
surprise at least it's in alignment with
the rumor that young morpheus will be
embodied by yaya abdulmatin
whatever the plans of the vakowski
sisters are at the end of the day
we would finally have love to see
lawrence fishburne in matrix 4.
what do you think do you find the
vakowski sisters move plausible
or would you have liked to see the old
morpheus as well
write it down in the comments
especially 80s and 90s kids will
remember a space jam
very well released in 1997 the mixture
of animation and live action film became
a true classic
especially thanks to the iconic
performances of michael jordan
now it is reported that lebron james
will follow in the footsteps of michael
jordan as the main actor and lead the
tune squad with bugs bunny and co
there's already a first teaser which
shows the basketball player in the
team's new jersey
unfortunately we don't get a serial
scenes from the movie yet
apart from lebron james appearances by
marvel star don chilan star trek
discovery actress soniqua martin green
are planned
while malcolm d lee will direct the
movie the u.s american launch of space
jam 2 a new legacy is july 16
2021
looking at this tweet it's hard to
believe that morgan creek will try to
reboot the horror classic the axis is
from 1973
but unexpectedly this is exactly what
will happen soon if you believe the use
magazine deadline
it is reported that a cinema reboot of
morgan creek entertainment is planned
for next year even though further
information has apparently not been
leaked yet
the story is based on a novel by william
peter blatty and mutated into one of the
best horror movies of all times thanks
to director william friedkin
after the us channel fox tried to put
the story into series in 2017 without
success
they have decided to reboot the original
we hope that we'll soon be able to tell
you more about the exorcist
because more than the expected start in
2021 is not
yet known
[Music]
bye